une protestation qui semble hélas bien
dérisoire au regard du terrible conflit
libanais qui est reparti de plus belle
si l'on peut dire
depuis quinze jours en jean clotaire
faire un dépôt de carburant en flamme
pour les chrétiens du liban d'un cercle
est au bord de la pénurie totale
ce n'est là pour tom qu'une péripétie
secondaire en comparaison des ravages
subis ces derniers jours ici il n'y a
pas eu de trêve pascale
les duels d'artillerie n'ont pas cessé
d'un côté les syriens et leurs alliés
druzes et chiites
des centaines de canon mais d'orgues de
staline pointé sur la zone chrétienne de
l'autre les forces chrétiennes bien
armée elle aussi retranché dans leur
réduit de 1500 kilomètres carrés entre
mer et montagne et qui rit fort soit 155
mm depuis hier on a retiré des ruines
huit morts et 42 blessés de part et
d'autre comme d'habitude ce sont les
civils qui paient le prix fort ici les
obus syriens sont tombés sur un centre
d'enfants handicapés
la nuit dernière il tombait soixante
obus à la minute sur les quartiers
chrétiens
damas veut écraser la détermination du
général aoun de chasser les trente cinq
mille soldats syriens de son pays et de
réunifier le liban le comité des bons
offices la ligue arabe s'est réuni
aujourd'hui à tunis mais en l'absence
des chefs de guerre druzes et chiites
walid joumblatt et nabih berry le sang
n'a donc pas fini de couler et une
centaine de roquettes se sont abattues
ce choix sur les quartiers chrétiens à
l'étranger toujours l'été a en revanche
a décidé de prolonger sa trêve jusqu'au
24 juin
dans l'attenté des résultats